>> PRASETYA: Hey, everyone, how are you guys
doing today? My name is Marcel Prasetya; I'm
one of the developers from the Google Wave
team working primarily on the Java Robot API.
So, this is just a breakdown of my presentation
today. First, I'm going to talk aboutóI'm
going to give you a brief introduction about
Robot and the architecture of our Robot API.
I'm also going to talk about the events and
operation system. And so, basically, it's
things that he robot receives and sends back
to our server, and we're going to also talk
about the different view objects that we have:
TextView, FontView and GadgetView that allows
you to read and modify Wave content in a simpler
way. And finally--and hopefully this is--this
will be the most interesting part. I'm going
to walk you through a short tutorial on how
to make Robot from scratch. So, Robot is a
robotic participant in a Wave that can basically
read and write Wave content inside a Wave
that--in which it participates. There are
several tasks of robots, and please keep in
mind, this is not a comprehensive list, but
we just want to give you an idea of--on, like
what kind of things that Robot can do. First
one is, we have Content Assist Robot. One
example of this will be CompleteIt that will
basically auto-complete your sentence in Google
Wave using Google search. We have Smiley that
Dave demoed. The second class is Data Synchronization
Robot. A good example of this will be Buggy
that--which is a robot that synchronizes your
Wave content with an issue tracking system.
We also have tweetie that synchronizes your
Wave content with Twitter. And we also have
a multi-wave applications robot. I don't know
whether if you guys have seen the Google I/O
presentation. We demoed one robot called Polly
that will basically let you create and distribute
holes into different waves. We also have a
bot called Blogbot that let's you manage blogs
and wave. The last class of robot that we
have is a compensational type of robot. One
good example of this is ELIZA. So, basically,
if you're lonely and if you're looking for
someone to talk to you, just add ELIZA to
your Wave and you'll be happy. Like Dave mentioned,
temporarily, Robot can only run in Google
App Engine. We're going to lift off this restriction
in the future. If a normal user has a participant
ID in the form of your username at wavesandbox.com
and Robot will have a participant ID in the
form of the application ID of your App Engine
account at Appspot.com. Now, let's talk about
the architecture of our Robot API. So the
heart of a Robot API is the server in the
middle called Robot Proxy. So that's basically
a server that listens for updates coming from
the Wave server and package it up in a JSON
format and broadcast that into your Robot
running on App Engine. That Robot Proxy is
also responsible for receiving operations
coming from your Robot and pushes that over
to Wave server. And so, the communication
format is over HTTP Protocol, and the data
that we send back and forth is in the form
of JSON. Okay. Now, let's talk about events
and operations. So events are basically something
that Robot subscribes to, and these are things
that are broadcasted by a Robot Proxy. We
have--I've listed some examples of events
that are commonly used. The first one is Wavelet
self added that gets triggered whenever Robot
gets added to a Wave. We have a blip submitted
event that gets triggered when a blip is submitted.
We have document change event that gets triggered
when content of a blip has changed. And we
also have many different events that you can
see from our API page. So whenever Robot receives
those events, it typically responds with a
series of operations that will be received
by Robot Proxy and then will transfer that
to Wave server. We have some sample--I have
some sample operations here. First one is
a pen--wavelet of pen blip that allows you
to create a new blip in a Wave. And we have
wavelets subtitle that lets you adjust the
title of the wave; and we have document insert,
document delete, set--document set annotation,
and so on.
Now, let's talk about the few objects. Wave
is basically an XML document with textual
and non-textual content. And then to provide
an abstraction on top of the gory details
of our XML schema, we provide some convenient
objects called a view object that basically
lets you manage your Wave content in a simpler
way. And--well, first one, we have TextView
that allows you to manage--that allows Robot
to manage textual content. We have methods
such as like append, replace, append style
text, the lead, and so on. We also have a
FormView object that lets you manage your
form elements like buttons, input text, text
area, radio button and stuff like that. Yes?
>> And that input content, is that referenced
to non-external...?
>> We're going to do questions at that panel.
That's what's that panel is for and I just
wanted to have--I mean--we're going to do
questions as a panel.
>> PRASETYA: Okay. So, the last view that
we have is a GadgetView that allows you to
manage your gadget from your Robot that can
set a feel--like set a state or got a state
of Robot and--add gadget, delete gadget. All
right. So enough theory, so I'm going to give
you a short tutorial on how to make Robot
from scratch. So basically, today, we're going
to build a robot called tweets, which is basically
a simplified version of tweetie. Since I'm
lazy and we're running out of time. Basically,
this Robot will not have a log-in form. The
username and password will be hard-coded inside
the code. I'm going to use my Twitter test
account. There are two use cases that this
robot will support. The first one is whenever
it receives a wavelet self added event, it
will fetch us a list of tweets from Twitter.
And the second use case is whenever it receives
a blip submitted event, it will submit the
content of that blip to Twitter as a tweet.
All right, how many of you guys have used
Google App Engine or Build Application at
all? Okay, so, great. So to build a Robot,
first thing that you need to do is you need
to have an AppID. So you do that by going
to the App Engine dashboard, and then you
can use an existing application or you can
create an application--a new application.
So in this case, I've registered an application
ID called tweet Wave that I registered a few
days ago, and I'm going to use that for today's
demo. So second thing after we set up an Application
ID is we need to download the client library.
So first, you need to go to our--the API's
website, code.google.com/API/wave. And then
clicks on the robot link and then click on
download. So you need to download these three
jars that we have. First one is our client
library, and then the next two are the dependencies
that the library depends on. Okay. Right.
So now I'm going to build a Java Robot using
Eclipse. I'm going to bring up Eclipse here.
I highly recommend that you use the Google
APP Engine or the Google Plug-in for Eclipse.
It has a seamless integration with APP Engine
and Google Web Toolkit that allows you basically
to create and deploy your APP Engine project
from within Eclipse seamlessly. So I'm going
to create a new project. I'm going to call
it tweets, put in a tweets package. And since
I'm not going to use Google Web Toolkit, I'm
going to uncheck this part right here.
Okay. Now, I have my new project. The next
thing is I need to copy the jars that I've
downloaded into my project. So I need to put
that in my lib directory inside the web end
directory, paste that, and then open Eclipse
again. And now I'm going to import those jars
into my project. Oh, first, I have to refresh.
Okay. I'm going to select the three jars that
I've downloaded and import it here. Okay.
So, now, I think we're ready to start building
a Robot now. So first, to build Robot, you
need to create a Robot configuration file
called the "capabilities.xml" file. So I'm
going to put that inside a directory called
_wave, and then I'm going to make a file called
"capabilities.xml." To save some time, I'm
just going to copy and paste from the existing
example. So this is a robot configuration
file. It basically tells Robot Proxy what
kind of events that this robot is interested
in. So in this example, I've listed two events.
So basically this robot will receive a wavelet
self-added event and also Eclipse-submitted
event from Robot Proxy. Okay, so now we have
the configuration file. I'm--now, let's start
implementing the servlet that will receive
the request coming from Robot Proxy. So APP
Engine creates this servlet for you, but I'm
going to change that. In the--as part of the
client library, we provide an abstract servlet
called AbstractRobotServlet that provides
some convenient methods for you to serialize
and de-serialize events and operations to
and from JSON. So in a typical Robot, you
just need to extend that AbstractRobotServlet
and then--override this one method called
process events. So this is basically the main
processing loop that will receive all incoming
events from Robot Proxy.
Okay. So now, now we're ready to implement
the first Use Case. So what we want to do
is when the robot gets added, we want to fetch
a list of tweets, right? So first we check
from the--using the bundle, RobotMessageBundle.
I'm going to rename this into Bundle. So first
we want to check whether this is a self-added
event or not. If it is, then I'm going to
fetch a list of tweets from Twitter.
So to speed things up a little bit, I created
this class called Twitter Service yesterday
that basically handles the interaction with
Twitter. It has--it provides two utility functions.
The one is to fetch tweets, and two is to
post tweets to Twitter. I'm hard coding my
username and password in there. Okay. So now
we have a list of tweets from Twitter. What
we want to do now is we want to post those
tweets as blips. So, we're going to iterate
over the tweets. And for each one of them,
we are going to make a blip.
So notice here, I'm calling from the bundle.
I'm calling the getWavelet event. That will
return me the wavelet. And then from that
wavelet, I'm calling the appendBlip method.
That returns me the new blip. So right now,
this blip is empty. So what I want to do is
I want to get the text view by calling the
GetDocument method. And then I want to call
Append method to append--and append the con--the
tweet.
Okay. So I think we're done with the first
Use Case. Now, let's deal with the second
Use Case. So what we want to do is that we
want to post blip content as tweet to Twitter.
So first, we need to--we need to check the
bundle, whether we have any blip submitted
events or not. Okay? And for each blip submitted
event, we want to get the actual blip.
And then from there, we want to get the text
view by calling the GetDocument. And then
we want to get the content of the text view
by calling GetText. And then we want to post
this to Twitter. I'm going to use my friendly
Twitter Service Class again. Call tweet method.
Okay. So now I think we have the servlet ready.
One thing is we need to check the web deployment
descriptor file. I'm going to open it up.
Call--this is the web XML file. So the one
thing is that we need to map the servlet that
we just created into the specific URL, the
specific path, so that is _wave/robot/jsonrpc.
So that's a convention that we have, robot
proxy with ping your robot at that specific
path. That's very important. And I don't need
this--this is the last one. Okay? And then--so
we have a configuration file. We have a servlet.
And then the last thing I want to create is
the extension file to install the Robot into
Wave. So I'm going to copy over this file
extension into my _wave directory. Just to
quickly go over this, so the name of this
extension is tweets and has this thumbnail
that I got from twitty-wave@appspot.com. And
then author is myself. And then this has a
"Create New Wave" hook. And then whenever
you click on that "Create New Wave" button,
it will add--it will make a new wave with
tweets-wave@appspot.com as the participant.
Okay. So before I deploy this to Google App
Engine, I want to try to run this locally
and see. Oh, and this is already used. Okay,
so I have my server running locally. A few
things that I want to check is first whether
I can access the capabilities.xml.
Okay. I have that. And then the second thing
that I want to check is whether I can access
the extension file.
And last thing I want to check is whether
I can ping the _wave/robot/jsonrpc path or
not. So good, we don't get a 404.
So now we have it all implemented locally,
we want to deploy this to Google App Engine.
So first, you need to open your App Engine
description file, appengine-web.xml. Now we
need to specify the application ID that we've
registered before. So in this case, I'm going
to use tweets-wave right here. And then I'm
going to click on this App Engine icon to
deploy this, uploading, okay, successful.
Okay. Now I have deployed that. Before--so
I want to check a few things again. First
I want to check whether I can access my extension
file. Good. And then also the capabilities
of that XML file.
Okay. Cool. Now, I'm going to go to Wave Sandbox,
and try out our new robot.
Okay. So first I'm going to create a new Wave
and install my extension. You can install
an extension on any Wave that you have or
you can make a new one. It's really up to
you. Extension installer, and then I'm going
to copy and paste my extension manifest file.
Oops, shinies, okay, I'm going to refresh.
All right, so that's my extension tweets and
then description is to create a new Wave filled
with tweets. So, I'm going to click install
here and then you--now you see the down arrow
here, next to the new Wave and then I can
create a new T-WAVE now. So, T-WAVE stands
for Twitter Wave. Just see there, Lars coined
that term. And I hope this works. I've just--uploading--
It doesn't. Oh, there you go. Okay. So, the
robot, whenever it gets added to Wave, like,
I told you before. So, it will fetch a list
of tweets, from Twitter. So, let's now--let's
verify that. So, I'm--logged in to Twitter
here, with my test account called Coco boat
(ph) and I have two tweets here, "What a beautiful
day and hello, twitter." So, we can verify
that, I have the exact same tweets, since
I Wave. I can--so that was the first use case
that tweets supports. Now, let's try out the
second use case. Hacking at Google Wave, Hackathon,
I can spell. So, after I submit this blip
we should be able to see that on Twitter.
So, I'm going to go back to my Twitter page
here and refresh. It doesn't show up. There
you go, Hacking at Google Wave, Hackathon.
As you notice here that the content of the
root blip is empty. So, I'm going to update
the code a little bit to make--to put some
text in there. So, I'm going to go back to
this "if" statement and then I will say from
the bundle, I'm going to get the wavelet and
from there I'm going to get the root blip
and then get the text view of the root blip
and then append the text. My tweets--and then
I'm going to deploy that again, to App engine.
Now, let's try that again, you T-WAVE. Okay.
For some reason it's running kind of slow.
But as you can see now, it updates the content
of the root blip with this text that I just
added to my tweet, which is "my tweets." Yeah.
So, I don't what happened with the--this--what
was that? We're going to try it one more time.
Oh, there we go. Cool. Whew. With that, so
that concludes my presentation. If you guys
have any questions for us, we'll be hanging
around for the panel and happy hacking. Sorry,
I move a little slower than I used to.